thank you very much Ron Corleone this
really attractive woman is my girlfriend
Lucy hello Lucy
Oh impressive handshake Thanks my father
told me little limp handshake was for
weak men and communists he made it both
well done Tommy
zette bacon on your turkey leg they call
it a Swanson Wow at least once a year I
like to bring in some of my Kevin's
famous chili the trick is to undercook
the onions everybody is going to get to
know each other in the pot I'm serious
about this stuff I'm up the night before
pressing garlic and dicing whole
tomatoes i toast my own ancho chiles
it's a recipe passed down from Malone's
for generations it's probably the thing
I do best
welcome to the Jimmy jabs we play for
pride we play for the phone numbers of
Rosa's friends but most importantly we
play to watch Amy lose nope this is my
ear that's my ear - please don't align
yourself with me why not neither of you
have ever come close to winning you're
exactly the same just a couple of
Santiago's but the real prize is the
winchester 3000 the only chair in the
precinct with minimal staining good
lumbar support and no broken Rolly
wheels over to you Gina Thank You Jake
okay guys as usual the loser of each
event is eliminated from the games the
winner gets a bonus in the final round
our first event is the mouth of fawn in
front of you is month-old Chinese food
from the fridge go ahead and eat as much
as you can
stomach on your mark get set
Wahlberg I can't do this to my mouth
she's the love of my life
Charles is eliminated oh I think this
ball of soup the top Wow I can do this
I'm gonna win so bad oh great here quick
let me take a picture oh that's so cute
you've got a little bit of mold on the
tip here knows I tried I tried
he's unbeatable you guys know this it's
free right this came out no I am
starving I haven't had lunch since
yesterday so I'm gonna head over to
callaghan's oh no no no don't go there
they totally skimp on pickles let me go
to bighead joes for you they have the
most insane burritos I don't much go for
ethnic food no trust me they have one
that's called the meat tornado literally
kill the guy last year you had me at
meat tornado beer Garth um wasn't
surrounded Kali was the fourth round
Indianapolis Colts know how to draft so
well they really do Andy this was
delicious it's awesome it's a whole new
meat delivery system thank you son
what'd you say we go out to the parking
lot run a few pass plays to burn off the
calories you are an unstoppable good
idea machine I like Andy I'm surrounded
by a lot of women in this department and
that includes the man up
hey man reading the defense Reggie wait
boner I have the best stocked survival
shelter in northeastern Pennsylvania but
everything has a shelf life so I must
eat and then replace everything that's
about to expire it's nice not to have to
plan my meals you're eating eight year
old Tomatoes
there's no good for another week you
know I think I might have some type of
cheese in the back of my fridge you
might like I've got some cheese you
might like to in between my toes
hardy-har-har all right picture this
snowy ash drizzles from the sky a rabid
pack of dogs surrounds yours the flame
at the end of your stick dies out
there's only one hope left for you the
door to my shelter you pound you beg
Dwight please let me in
but I ignore your cries and do not let
you in you want to know why because of
the sign that says no pounding no
begging no because you laughed at me
Kevin will be eaten Pam will be taken
slave Jim will be made a warlords jester
Meredith will do okay be assured this
day will come it's just a matter of time
could be one month could be two months
three months okay babe four months I see
that happening yes
eight months that's a realistic timeline
11 months perhaps okay wait I'll really
think hard about this one one year I
could see that as a very real
possibility 494 months I could see that
happening 495 months that's just he Rosa
the Flatbush diners pie is terrible it's
inedible food is supposed to be able so
you were lying what the hell Boyle
put it in the psyche of a gift crust
isn't any better
it's fancier but it's all bells and
whistles desserts don't need to be
clever they just need to be good this is
the best pie in New York City Apple from
Argos bakery founded 1910 recipe
unchanged taste it you just graduated
high school [ __ ] sorry I said [ __ ]
I'm just really worked up I couldn't
care less about the commendation
but Indianapolis is home to Charles
Mulligan's Steakhouse the best damn
Steakhouse in the damn State
I have taken a picture of every steak
I've ever eaten there June 2004
porterhouse medium-rare Bearnaise sauce
January 2000 they call this one the
enforcer February 96 a steak ribeye the
whiskey Lagavulin 16 the lady next to me
a [ __ ] specifically my ex-wife Tammy
okay this is this is the first time I
ever went there gonna be just a kid
once a year they bring in a little cart
and they give away free pretzels it's
really not a big deal
to some people it is productivity is
important but how can I be productive if
I have this one little thing in my brain
that I cannot get out and that one
little thing is a soft pretzel so I'm
just gonna have my soft pretzel I got to
work and I'm gonna be super productive
look out for me
I wake up every morning in a bed that's
too small driving my daughter to a
school that's too expensive and then I
go to work to a job for which I get paid
too little but on pretzel day a lot of
my pretzel day and I'll have the number
8 that's a party platter that serves 12
people I know what I'm about son all
right party time
I would suggest sticking around and
watching him eat it cuz it only takes
four minutes and it's pretty amazing
these will not be necessary
a last meal on earth that's a great
question I'd go classic french Ortolan
honey songbird eaten a single bite bones
and all and open defiance of God it's
illegal to consume Ortolan but I
actually got academic dispensation to
eat one once the beak very crunchy that
is literally the sexiest thing anyone
has ever said how are you single
you're not seeing anyway
no there's nobody in my life sort of a
sad thing to wink about I realize now
it's rough in here is it always like
this
I wouldn't know don't like strip clubs
smells like a wet mop in here and I get
the feeling that every one of these
women is running a low-grade fever
you're one of the good ones run wait a
minute
hello beautiful
[Music]
strippers do nothing for me I like a
strong salt-of-the-earth self-possessed
woman at the top of her field your
Steffi Graf's your Sheryl Swoopes is but
I will take a free breakfast buffet
anytime anyplace
you